bonsoir alexis quel était selon soir les
enjeux de cette visite des manuels
macron ce matin alors visite extrêmement
symbolique je crois qu'ils en jeu
c'était de faire une pause dans la
communication kovy de faire ce parallèle
pompiers entre la reconstruction le
courage des pompiers à l'époque
justement et le courage des soignants
devant cette crise sanitaire et de
montrer combien la france est résiliente
combien elle est capable de faire face à
toutes les crises et puis de sortir un
nouveau déguisement à chaque jour son
nouveau déguisement aujourd'hui on avait
aimé macro ouvrier de chantier hier on
avait aimé le maquereau ou psychologues
et avant-hier on avait mal macron avec
les vaccins lambus blanche bon voilà
c'est quelque chose que le président
adore enfiler des costumes
le voilà donc au sommet de notre dame en
étant cassure dans son discours
velléitaire de dire que oui elle sera
reconstruite en cinq ans comme il
l'avait dit à l'époque il ya deux ans
lors du drame
on le voit bien le responsable des
travaux du comité de reconstruction de
notre dame
le général georgelin lui est plus mesuré
en pensant que il faudra des années
avant de pouvoir ré ouvrir de finir les
travaux et les offices pourront
peut-être prendre en 2024 mais rien de
moins sûr
alors oui il faut se féliciter bien
entendu les artisans mobiliser les
ouvriers mobilisés sur sur ce chantier
d'importance mais je trouve que ce
parallèle assez grossier assez évident
entre la cathédrale le travail des
pompiers qui éteignent un fait
incroyable et de travail des soignants
qui éteignent le feu du coc vide
on s'est un peu de la communication
facile sans doute ça ne fait pas de mal
à l'image d'emmanuel maquereau ou bien
écornée puisque et bien ce soir il tient
une réunion sur l'organisation de la
réouverture alors il y avait eu un
premier déconfinement a mené par jean
castex qui nous a amenés à de plus
confinement de plus et là peut-être
qu'il va y avoir une réouverture romaine
et qui sera très progressive et la
mi-mai par est déjà un objectif
difficile à tenir tandis que nos voisins
anglais ont réouvert les pubs et ça
c'est des images qui font mal dans la
communication présidentielle et ce
message ce parallèle entre en chantier
de notre dame de paris la lutte contre
le communisme n'a fait ce cas est-ce
qu'il fonctionne auprès des français
alors je ne sais pas je pense que
certains français sont réceptifs à ce
genre de communication symbolique
elle est facile évidemment il y a dans
cette façon de communiquer des macros et
dans l'utilisation des déguisements des
costumes c'est envie toujours de donner
d'abord l'importance à la forme plutôt
qu'au fond et on voit bien que parfois
ça marche alors cessé quand on est
commentateur de la vie politique on
regarde ça c'est plutôt désolant mais ça
peut marcher mais auprès de certaines
personnes et on voit que c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement réfléchir puisque il
ya eu une interview dans le parisien où
les mots sont choisis en parlant de ses
pompiers petites lucioles dans la nef du
plomb fondu qui tombait encore lorsqu'il
était rentré dans notre dame mutilés
tout ça est vraiment écrit aux petits
oignons on imagine les communicants
pendant des semaines déjà préparé ce
rendez vous puisque on sent bien que
c'est à une stratégie communicationnelle
une pause dans le vide pour justement
redémarrer trouver un second souffle
edit ah bon ben maintenant on a les
vaccins seulement voilà les vaccins et
bien ils n'arrivent pas que ce soit à
strazeele et cas où on voit que ça
continue les quoique le danemark qui fit
préfère arrêter là la vaccination avec
astrazeneca l'autorité du médicament la
commission européenne qui dit qu'elle ne
renouvellera pas les contrats
d'astrazeneca et de johnson & johnson et
puis johnson & johnson
ce vaccin qui va être livré en retard
même si la france a décidé de vacciner
tandis que d'autres pays comme l'afrique
du sud ou la suède eux préfèrent
attendre et prendre le temps d'évaluer
ce vaccin donc toute la communication
sur le co vide est en panne sèche à la
fois sur le calendrier de réouverture
sur le calendrier de l'acsi nation il
fallait donc trouver un peu d'air et ce
moment notre dame lui permet bien sûr de
parler un certain électorat attaché aux
traditions à la culture française et de
montrer combien pour lui c'est important
sans oublier bien sûr la gestion au
quotidien de la crise comme lui de même
si on n'a pas l'impression que c'est au
sommet de ses priorités
le sommet temps comment organiser une
campagne de réélection dans des
conditions aussi délétère et justement
emmanuel un camp qui assure qu' assurer
que les délais de reconstruction de la
cathédrale seront tenues un nouvel
engagement
un nom de la présidentielle un
engagement difficile à tenir oui un
engagement mais encore une fois tant de
promesses non tenues qui font que les
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui
veulent bien les croire en politique
donc emmanuel macron en usent et en
abusent
rappelez vous il ya six semaines à il
nous disait qu'il fallait tenir encore
six semaines bon ben voilà on est encore
confiné avec un couvre-feu 19 heures là
il dit que oui ça tiendra cinq ans
pourquoi pas il ne sera jamais comptable
finalement de cette façon de faire il y
a tellement d'adp de boursouflures
communicationnel dans ce gouvernement
que tout ça peut passer finalement avec
la mémoire de poisson rouge de l'opinion
publique
on oublie très vite que il y a eu autant
de couacs autant de choses je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il ya d'autres priorités
on le voit bien d'ailleurs sondage après
sondage que les françaises sont d'abord
préoccupés par l'avenir de l'avenir de
leurs emplois l'avenir de la croissance
leur précarisation ou non et puis
aujourd'hui il ya une crise majeure au
dessus du comité c'est celle du gel pour
l'ensemble des maraîchers qui eux
attendent aussi des réponses assez forte
compte tenu de la difficulté qu'ils vont
avoir à produire suffisamment de fruits
que soit la vigne où les producteurs de
maraîchers donc on voit bien que ça part
un peu dans tous les sens qu'il y avait
là une stratégie de communication claire
défini de ceux déguisés en ouvriers de
monter au sommet de notre dame de
rappeler combien les pompiers avaient
été courageux et combien ils ressemblent
aux soignants ça ne suffira peut-être
pas pour remonter dans les sondages
merci beaucoup pour votre un décryptage
alexis est poulain